in this video we'll talk about the
process of gastrulation and focusing on
the human gastrulation angle
gastrulation is a set of coordinated
movement which is very important for an
embryonic development according to the
famous embryologist Louis walpart it's
not birth marriage or death but
gastrulation which is truly the most
important time of your life so what
really happens during gastrulation
during the gastrulation process the
cells of blastula are given new
positions they migrate into a new
neighborhood in a very coordinated
fashion and that's the key time to
establish body axis and different Jam
layers
so here is AP blast and the cells of the
AP blast would be reorganized in a
coordinated fashion to give rise to
layers like endoderm ectoderm and
misoderm in short that is the process of
gastrulation
now this movement is not haphazard this
movement is highly coordinated and each
movement has features and there are
different kinds of movement that can
possibly occur during gastrulation like
invagination involution integration
delamination or even epiboli now all
these movements are not happening all at
once
there could be a combination of movement
that can occur in one organism and this
kind of morphogenetic movements are
different throughout the different
Animal Kingdom I have a different video
on morphogenetic movement
so in this video if we cut a long story
to short we would understand that
gastrulation is all about coordinated
movements of a pool of cells
and this movement involves the entire
embryo
and patterns of gastrulation could vary
throughout the animal kingdom there
could be different types of movements
happening during gastrulation
now all the patterns of movement doesn't
happen at once a combination of these
morphogenetic movements that we
discussed happens during gastrulation
and we'll take an example of the human
embryo to understand this better
so this is about the end of second week
of human gestation
point of time
the blastocyst is implanted into the
uterine wall
So at around day 15 you can see a
distinct chorionic cavity here is the
Primitive stock and you can see the
embryo is hanging through the Primitive
stock
so now let's look at the embryo in 3D so
here in red you can see the AP blast
which would eventually give rise to the
embryo and here is the hypoblast which
would give rise to the yolk sac
so basically it's amniotic cavity which
is in between the epiblast cells and it
is yolk Sac between the hypoglass cells
during the process of gastrulation the
bilaminar embryonic disc
which is composed of epiblast and
hypoblast ultimately gives rise to
ectoderm mesoderm and endoderm
and this process happens in a
coordinated fashion over a period of
time
so let's look at the embryo in 3D so we
can look at the embryo hanging in the
chorionic cavity and here is the
amniotic cavity in the embryo and here
is a yolk sac
so at this point of time at the caudal
end of the embryo A Primitive streak
forms
and this is a thickening
which contains a midline Groove
and it forms the mid sagittal plane of
the embryonic disc
over the course of next day this
thickening which is known as the
Primitive streak elongates and occupy
almost half the
span of the embryonic disc
and thereby the Primitive Groove is
formed
so at the cranial end of this primitive
streak
there is a formation known as the
primitive node
so this primitive node is really
important to understand the process of
gastrulation
and a depression at around the Primitive
node is formed which is known as the
Primitive pit it contains a depression
now the cells move through the Primitive
streak
inside
the embryo and this is this process is
known as ingression
so let's leave the jargon and try to
understand what is ingression but during
gastrulation AP blast cells move towards
the Primitive streak enter through the
Primitive streak and then migrate away
from the Primitive streak as an
individual cell so overall lot of
cellular aspects are associated with
this process let us try to understand
this better
so Follow the arrow to look at the cell
movement first of all these cells are
moving towards the Primitive streak
through the permissive streak and moving
away the Primitive streak inside from
the inside of the embryo
so this is the integration process now
if we look at the cross section of the
embryo we can appreciate this movement
look at the arrow and see how the cells
move first inward then downward and then
again Inward and this movement is
ingression and it is key to understand
the formation of the charm layers
now here we are looking at the epiblast
and hypoblast from our top view
and this if we cut a cross section along
this angle we would have a view like
this
one thing is to one thing is important
to note that there is a pro or
pre-codile plate which is defining the
cranial end of the embryo the
pre-cordial plate contributes to the
oropharyngeal membrane a two layered
membrane that would eventually be
ruptured to give rise to the mouth
opening also this pre-cordial or Pro
chordal plate works like an important
signaling Center which is crucial for
the neural tube formation
now if we Orient ourselves towards the
embryo this is the chordal end there is
a cranial and Left Right End
now there are certain signaling
happening which is allowing the
formation of the Primitive trick
so the Primitive streak induction
happens
via activity of wind TGF beta Etc
and in the cranial end there are uh
molecules which counteracts this wind
activity and thereby a gradient is
generated and along this gradient a
cranial to caudal axis is formed so this
is the induction of the Primitive streak
and this is the formation of the
Primitive streak which triggers the
process of ingression
now formation of the definitive endoderm
is the next process at around day 16
many of the AP blast cells move inside
by the process of ingression which is
one type of morphogenetic movement and
they populate the inside of the embryo
eventually they replace the cells in the
hypoblast layer and eventually form the
definitive endoderm
so first the
cells need to detach from the epiblast
layer and this happens via process known
as epithelial to mesenchymal transition
if you want to learn more about EMT
click on the I button
so the first Ingress ingressing AP blast
cells invent the hypoblast and displace
its cells to create the definitive into
term
some of the epithelial cells migrating
migrating through the Primitive streak
diverge into the space between the
epiblast and the definitive Hindu term
and this is kind of like the intra
embryonic mesoderm so this layer in
Violet would be eventually becoming the
mesoderm of the embryo so this Violet
cells are actually going to give rise to
the misoderm
and at the last the
term forms so once the formation of the
definitive endoderm and intra-embryonic
mesoderm is complete AP blast cells no
longer need to move towards an Ingress
through the Primitive streak so they
eventually give rise to the ectoderm
layer and thereby three germ layer
formation is kind of complete
so what we learned so far gastrulation
is nothing but choreographed series of
movements which helps to form three
important jump layers known as ectoderm
mesoderm and endoderm and each of these
germ layers are important for
organogenesis for example if we look at
the ectoderm it give rise to central
nervous system brain skin Adrenal
medulla to name a few
then mesoderm give rise to kidney
reproductive system bone heart and
spleen whereas endoderm give rise to GI
tract liver endocrine system urethra
bladder Etc so obviously gastrulation is
the first Milestone that has to be
achieved during the process of
development eventually there would be
many modifications and influences from
inside and outside environment
the very next thing that happens is the
neural tube formation
neural tube formation is a complicated
process and in the next video we would
talk about the neural tube so if you
look at the embryo from a top view right
now and a cross section view you can
completely imagine that this flat sheet
of ectodermal cells are eventually
folding to form a tube-like organization
and this is the neural tube eventually
our brain is nothing about but a tube at
one side it is blown up like a balloon
in the brain side and other side it's
tippering in the spinal cord so in a
next video we'll talk about the neural
tube folding process and the defects
associated with neural tube folding
so stay tuned for more you can get more
flash cards and notes in my Facebook
page or Instagram page you can support
our Channel using super tanks or you can
pay via PayPal or UPI see you in next
video